Here the correct answers were 2 plus or minus i times root 6. That's amazing
work if you got these answers correct. We want to start by dividing each term
of our equation by 3. So dividing each of these by 3 we'll get x squared minus
4x plus 10 equals 0. Now we're in a position to complete the square. Our a term
is one, and our b term is even. We subtract 10 from both sides to get x squared
minus 4x equals negative 10. We complete the square by adding 4 to both sides
of the equation. This gives us the quantity, x minus 2 squared equal to
negative 6. Then, we take the square root of both sides of the equation to get
x minus 2 equals positive or negative i root 6. We add 2 to both sides to solve
for x. And these are the two solutions.